another meeting on school safety at the
White House a day as Congress moves to
take action President Trump winning some
rare praise from the Senate's top
Democrat for signalling he's open to
changing our nation's gun laws I'd like
to give credit where credit is due the
president said a lot of things right
yesterday he seemed to strongly endorse
universal background checks to ensure
that people who shouldn't have a gun
don't have access to one importantly the
president acknowledged that taking
meaningful steps to improve gun safety
is going to require bucking the NRA so
the meeting and the president's comments
were an encouraging step she were
unveiled a three-part gun control plan
from Democrats today he insists a ban on
assault weapons be part of the Senate
debate Marco Rubio pitched his own set
of proposals including confiscating guns
from those who pose a threat
president Trump supports that idea but
not the NRA I like taking the guns early
like in this crazy man's case that just
took place in Florida he had a lot of
fires they saw everything to go to court
would have taken a long time take the
guns first go through due process
there's a way that you can respect and
protect due process and protect the
rights of millions of Americans while
also hardening our schools and keeping
kids safe so great guys Senator Schumer
said that they will introduce a bill and
that they expect that it's possible I'm
sorry I just came in so I'm reading it
off my phone could pass Schumer proposal
with mostly Democratic support and a few
Republicans encouraged by President
Trump your thoughts not gonna happen
that bill isn't gonna happen I can
safely say that any when you with that
language it's not gonna work I think
what President Trump was trying to get
at and he used I think imprecise
language is he's talking about a
database for what he calls the crazy
guys a database where if school
officials and police officers notice
something wrong it's not about due
process actually that is the due process
they say this person is a threat but he
he hasn't violated any laws yet but they
say this is right there needs to be a
database for that where that person goes
and then you figure it out later but at
that point there's no gun and it's in a
civil court so there's a low bar and you
can go and get a judge to it to get you
know do a court order I think that's
what he's getting at but I I don't know
and I think that's a smart move because
I think that makes sense along with you
know hard hardening soft targets and
dealing with the mentally ill these are
all practical things I think what the
Dems are doing which is very smart is
they're they're piling there are other
stuff on there because and they're
saying they're lauding him whenever you
get praise from you're liberal you
should be very worried but I think we've
talked about this before if if there's a
Republican who moves to the middle you
know it's going to be Trump because he's
a populist and a populist when the
populist hear somebody say don't take
away my guns he'll say I'm with you and
then if somebody else says get those
guns away from those creeps he'll say
I'm with you because a populist is with
the popular opinion and that and if the
population has two different opinions he
will say yes to both of them well I
think what's happening too is that Jesse
there there's the conversation that's
happening in Washington and that
conversation might not actually lead to
legislation but there is movement in the
States so for example Rick Scott the
governor of Florida they've passed the
law to increase the age to 21 in terms
of purchase and he's going to dedicate
500 million dollars to harden the to all
the schools that's a huge commitment for
a state when you could spend it on a lot
of other things that's an enormous
commitment and he's feeling a lot of
heat down there in Florida it looks like
he's doing the right thing so far I do
get nervous when crying Chuck endorses
something I makes me run in the other
direction but in this case I think with
the president when he was using
imprecise language as you would say it's
a gun violence restraining order and so
if someone hasn't committed a crime or
hasn't been involuntarily committed to a
mental institution
but is killing animals and acting crazy
and beating up his mother and is a mess
like the kid was in Florida you go to a
judge there's due process you say let's
prevent him from buying a weapon or take
the weapon away Rubio supports this
legislation I don't see anything wrong
with that
in terms of the promise program they
want to redo these cops
we're dealing with this violent
ridiculous person down there causing
mayhem and they weren't treating him
like a criminal sometimes you have to
treat an 18 year old high school kid
like a criminal
and stop suspending him and putting him
time out and maybe actually make him pay
the price the background checks I can
agree with I think that's common sense
it's all about sharing information
whether it's you're suspended for
violence whether it's it's a crisis at
your house and you've been called the
police 55 times or whatever it is put
that into some sort of system and make
sure everybody has access to it the
raising the age limits I'm still a
little wishy-washy I haven't decided yet
I see the one hand you don't want an 18
year old person maybe to get a gun but
at the same time they are at the same
time that wouldn't have prevented most
of these mass shootings most of these
mass shootings are people above 18 and
if you're a hunter if you like sports
shooting and you're in a rural state why
deny them their constitutional rights I
don't get that one is there something
that the Democrats are seen either in
focus groups are polling or gut instinct
that they think this is an issue that is
ripe now for them to be able to put
forward this law and say well we might
be able to actually pass it no to the
contrary I mean the the politics of gun
control in this country are pretty clear
which is its most Americans who favor as
Jesse just said universal background
checks closing gun show loopholes going
after assault weapons most its gun
owners and non gun owners but what is
say going after assault weapons I don't
think that's okay no I'm saying that
okay I said most used by the gun show
loophole that I keep hearing most
Americans favor doing away with salt
weapons but the thing is that gun owners
are single vote type of people I mean
they will vote sing on a single issue
and that's guns people who favor gun
control are not single issue voters and
therefore their opposition is diluted
but in this moment with the young people
down in Florida leading the way I think
you're seeing a shift in opinion and the
question is whether or not the shift is
on the right and I think that's why
pretty much like Greg said senator Ben
Sasse in Nebraska said the president's
reflecting the last person to talk to
him and then you had people like
Breitbart saying oh it's Trump's
gun grab so you see the people on the
right reacting as if oh my god what's
Trump doing but people on the Democratic
side or on the left are like well let
him do what he wants to do but he's got
a fight among people who supported him
in 2016 and even with the plans that
he's put forward can it get 60 votes in
the Senate without strong Republican
support can it get 218 in the house yeah
that's Kevin Lee why I said that maybe
if let's just not saying legislation
can't pass this year but it is unlikely
I think that it would pass this year but
in the States you're doing things you're
seeing things and also the market is
sort of dealing with some of this
yesterday Walmart said that it would no
longer that it was raising the age limit
to 21 for its stores and also Kroger
said the same thing which I've always I
didn't know that they sold guns there I
thought that was like a grocery store
yeah look I think definitely some of you
said I found to be very interesting
which was maybe there is kind of like a
bit of a shift and perhaps maybe in some
sense on the right and certainly we're
seeing a little bit with you know the
president he's trying to be very
open-minded listen to both sides
evaluate the situation because perhaps
with the young people that were so
personally and tragically affected by
this it has changed a little bit of the
tone and the willingness to listen to
try to do something better because it's
not politicians although some of them
were motivated in certain ways by
different you know parental ideology and
whatnot I'm but that's what I think
people are listening well it's not this
congressman or this Republican or this
Democrat it's people who are their
experience loss and tragedy and
suffering and they're being real in
terms of how they experienced it and
genuine in terms of wanting to do
something about it even the first lady
commented on that and it's good the
children are using their voice and
they're trying to get it out there to do
something so it doesn't happen again to
somebody else and that's why I think you
see the president making this shift
yesterday Michael Hammond he's the
Legislative Council for Gun Owners of
America Greg he said talking about the
president we believe he's gone from in
his own words the second amendments best
friend to the gun grabber in chief and
that had Trump not run
on support of the second amendment he
would not be President of the United
States today those could be both be true
we knew this when we talked on the five
he had very I would say Center liberal
beliefs for a long time about about guns
and and and and then he went you know he
knew what he knew who he had to please
but this is this is what it's like when
you get a populist and and for better or
for worse we you know they're people are
very Pro populist but you never know
what the next day is gonna bring because
it's based on popular opinion here's my
concern what worries me is we're gonna
end up punishing law-abiding citizens
yeah not just in guns though right in
other arenas for example if you think if
you decide to rig this system to to make
it harder for legal citizen law-abiding
citizens to get guns you're not
targeting the actual troubled the nuts
right the civil tag system targets the
people who need to be target you put
them in a database I'm seen this
happening with opioids right now Donald
Trump talking about suing the government
suing pharmacies for pharmaceutical
companies so they're targeting
law-abiding citizens because of a tiny
percentage of abuse right they're gonna
go after the companies that create the
drugs and they're gonna go after either
gonna make it harder for cancer patients
and people with with illnesses to get
opioids because they're it's abuse now
there's a small amount of piece it is it
a parallel argument to guns the
overwhelming majority of people who use
grab guns are law-abiding citizens
citizens the people that use legal
medications are law-abiding people with
cancer with pain disorders we are
punishing people by creating a by going
after the system than actually going
after the system abusers well I think we
are going after the idea that there's
been such a proliferation of guns in
American society has there been
medications Asia do see my point no I
could deploy put on deliberation of
legal medication there's a difference
between a medication that actually has a
purpose in terms of healing your body a
gun has a purpose well gun is purpose in
terms of you would say self-defense for
example right right it is what I'm
saying to you that could other societies
people are able to defend themselves and
we have a problem with mass murders in
the society but I argue that since the
90s but my argument is that we now get
the gun owners of America which is to
the right of the NRA don't forget that
they are more radical than the NRA on
guns so they are now putting pressure on
the NRA so can the NRA say you know what
mr. president is apparently that that's
what he said they told him in the lunch
we're willing to do something we
understand we want to make our nation
safer our children safer as Kimberly was
saying but can they say that out loud
without getting you know whiplash I have
to say I'm the gun owners